[Music]
so we are here in Singapore
it's 10:30 right now Annie really wanted
breakfast this morning I also already
ate breakfast oh my gosh wait seriously
yeah where are we right now we are at
Gitmo market Center one of the best
Hawker Center Hawker Center is just like
a bunch of really really good food
stalls
let's go eat you could help us order
yeah sure yo Singaporean dollars I'm
talking about the 50:10 who is this guy
that one
yo this dish is so much Chi Cheung fun
next thanks this is the carrot cake
stall there's like the black version
there is the white version and then
we're gonna get both because it tastes
different this is 250 this is the hidden
luxury that's Singapore we're running
out of hand we're done grab the food
down there - much better already there
is a service that delivers soccer food
to your office
can they deliver to buzzfeed can we get
them
[Music]
wait whoa whoa whoa what is this what is
this
so this green mo we've uh this is our
friend Ryan they make food videos here
in Singapore we have these foods talking
what is really goo is it like okay fast
food we're just gonna get Malay food
Monsieur ah the best food
[Music]
all right what should we eat first let's
have some fun
this is rice cake with sesame teas on
top and then the soft looks like it's
some sort of sweets very satisfying to
just poke you would eat without why are
you chewing breakfast savory jello blue
eggs melts in your mouth like oh it's
also a nice fight it's almost like I'm
drinking that it's so good
that's the good stuff you know you don't
have to work to eat your food yeah I can
just go down your gullet it's the same
like radish and stuff but like in terms
of taste it's not the same eggs radish
scallion and it's all like fried
together like I'm like a fried rice yeah
Birds hanging over there all right Alice
I mean you got enough bird footage what
is this oh I believe there's carrot in
there no Cheers it's just like fried
rice like it's like already so full I
want to eat this every morning okay that
same thing but even sauce yeah
what it's still sweet it's still salty
it's just like a step up a theme that
we're having is everything's very soft
[Music]
all right Annie don't you yet yes
I've never had that kind of noodle
consistency where a new bid yeah I don't
know I love Malaysia song curries
because they're like milder you can like
just drink up all of it but it's not
something like lights I doesn't like to
feel your stomach up too much like I'm
very sure you don't want to show your
ship chill like it's so good they say
like oh my gosh this is so show it was
like an Indian thank you
rice and coconut meat with mind goes
straight to this what is it
curry those sugar and coconut oh my gosh
sugar it's almost like a crepe the point
of this is to absorb the flavors of
whatever you think right huh no sugar is
really good it's my favorite why this
orange it's my child
it's like straight up with her it's like
cotton candy
so good right the alphas really crispy
it's like a crepe in the inside is more
like a doughy bread and I gotta say that
curry is the way to go here
sugar team sugar team spice baby I want
to go to sleep
are you guys sure sure I'm sure wait how
did I get shuts aw shucks
yeah sure out he's my son
not sure it's okay
trust s H I okay drop sure they just
shook like shocked and stuck together
no you said Israel